we have a voicemail number the number is
2192 David P I made a mistake last week
and I apologize for it
I'll remind you what the mistake was and
it relates to Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory
Violet Beauregard turns into a blueberry
not Augustus glue Augustus Gloop
um he is so fat that he gets stuck in
the whatever
tubing system is carrying the chocolate
outside of her
but it was Violet Beauregard he swelled
to the blue to the size of a blueberry
and turned blue yeah so last week we
were talking on the bonus show that you
know the bonus show I hope oh the bonus
show where you want to make money yes
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad we were talking about
the effort to rewrite elements of Roald
Dahl's books including Willy Wonka uh
the Willy Wonka's chocolate factory
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory will I
forget that with the book and movie have
a different name in any case one of the
things is they don't like Augustus Gloop
being described as enormously fat
anymore that's I guess wrong so
Publishers want to change it to
something else and I was describing you
know he's like he swells like a
blueberry but that is not the story it
is indeed Violet that swells like a
blueberry an Augustus Gloop is the one
who gets like stuck in the piping I
guess of the Chocolate Factory I was
wrong about what I said my analysis is
the same which I am again against the
rewriting of books I think the book is a
complete Act
it is not to be now retrospectively
modified yes Roald Dahl was a horrible
anti-semite that's a separate issue
from whether we should mess with the
vocabulary in the book
uh and we had an extensive conversation
about this with Pat on the bonus show
which I welcome you to check out but I
was wrong in my retelling of the story
and I apologize we have a great bonus
show for you today Democrats have seen a
major shift and now prefer Joe Biden as
the nominee interesting an Idaho bill
would criminalize giving mRNA vaccines
what why you can probably guess and the
Pentagon is warning that poppy seed
Bagels could be a threat to National
Security yes it is related to the
Seinfeld episode about the poppy seed
Bagel so we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
please do yourselves a favor sign up at
joinpakman.com before they take your
machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines before they
take your phone and your espresso
machine and your desktop computer and
all of it get a membership at
joinpakman.com I'll see you on the bonus
show